hey everyone it's Sam registered nurse
Orion comm and in this video I want to
demonstrate for you how to kill a
respiratory rate this is one of those
very important bottles on skills that
you have to do as a nurse or a nursing
assistant so in this video what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go over the
basics of killing a respiratory rate and
then I'm going to show you how to do it
on a real person so first let's cover
the basics whenever you are looking at
the respiratory rate on a patient you're
looking for several things first thing
you're going to be looking at is the
rhythm and you're going to look at the
breathing effort of the patient whenever
you're looking at the rhythm you're
looking at to see if it's regular or
irregular and what you're paying
attention to is that in Spiteri phase
and that expert ory phase the
inspiratory phase is whenever they
inhale take a breath in an expert or a
phase is whenever they exhale take a
breath out and what you're looking at is
to make sure that they are equal because
in some patients for instance patients
with chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease COPD the excretory phase will be
a little bit longer than the inspiratory
phase so they'll take a breath in and
then they'll breathe out and it'll be a
lot longer now next thing you're going
to look for is how's the patient
breathing
are they having difficulty moving air
are they having dis me aware they're
going or is it just effortless for them
they're not really even aware that
they're breathing just like how you're
blinking so you want to pay attention to
that next you want to count that
breathing rate you want to make sure
that it is within the normal range for
an adult a normal range is 12 to 20
breaths per minute so we're making sure
that they meet that criteria so to do
this typically what you do is whenever
you go in to do your bottle signs you'll
collect them and you'll count a radial
pulse by feeling on the radial artery
and you'll count that for 30 seconds if
it's regular and then while you're still
holding a radial pulse site you are
going to look at the chest of the
patient
you are looking to see how that test is
rising and falling and you're counting
those rising the rising in the falling
as one breath because one inspiration
and one expiration equals one breath and
you're going to do that for 30 seconds
and after 30 seconds you'll take that
number multiply by 2 and that is your
respiratory rate so the reason you want
to hold the radial pulse while you're
counting the patients respirations is
because if a patient knows that you're
counting their respirations they're
going to throw them off and it's just
like blinking if you tell someone I'm
going to measure how much you blink the
person is going to be aware of how much
they're blinking and they're going to be
conscious of it and they're it's going
to throw what the normal rate would be
so after you get done counting the
respirations let them know that you were
counting the respirations now let me
show you how to count respirations on a
person hi my name is Sarah and I'm going
to be your nurse today and I'm going to
take your vital signs is that okay with
you absolutely
okay so I've performed hand hygiene and
we're going to get his bottle songs so
let me see your wrist and I want to feel
your pulse
okay so your pulse rate was 70 and your
respiration rate was 20 so that is how
you kill a respiratory rate now be sure
to check out my other videos on how to
do other nursing skills and thank you so
much for watching and please consider
subscribing to this YouTube channel